[Music]
welcome back everyone
so today i'm really excited to tell you
about a new paper uh that i recently
co-authored with ricardo vinuesa
pictured here
on using machine learning to enhance
computational fluid dynamics
so this was kind of ricardo's idea to
to write a paper like this and
i essentially helped out with the
reduced order modeling and some of the
some of the machine learning stuff
but this was a really fun collaboration
uh between the two of us and i learned a
ton
in the process of of kind of developing
these ideas with with ricardo
so the idea is that machine learning
kind of uh the broad class of machine
learning which i like to say is building
models from data with optimization and
regression
this broad class of machine learning
can be used to accelerate
direct numerical simulations so these
are our highest fidelity simulations of
fluid flows
they can be used also to accelerate and
improve the scaling of turbulence
closure models these are kind of
approximate models that still capture
lots of scales and features we care
about
the two most common are large eddy
simulations les and reynolds average
navier stokes rans and i have a whole
video series on how
deep learning can be used for for
turbulence modeling
and then we also talk about how these
machine machine learning techniques can
be used to improve physical
understanding uh and kind of scalability
and generalizability
uh both for these turbulence models but
also for uh classical reduced order
models so what we have here below is a
progression from the highest fidelity
most expensive way we can simulate a
fluid this gets all of the details and
simulates the full flow physics
all the way down to our very very
fast efficient
but highly tailored and customized
solutions these reduced order models
and typically reduced order models only
work for a really small subset of flows
and configurations whereas direct
numerical simulations are more general
and generalizable
and this turbulence modeling is kind of
in the middle
so at the outset i want to point out
some things that we are not doing in
this paper so we are are really
specifically focusing on how machine
learning can enhance computational fluid
dynamics simulating fluid flows in a
computer
so we don't talk uh much at all about
how machine learning can be used for
experimental methods and fluids like
particle image velocimetry and super
resolution things like that
and we're also not talking too much
about how you use machine learning for
things like control or sensor placement
and there are a number of uh of good
reviews out there for kind of the
broader picture of machine learning and
fluid mechanics
i wrote one of these reviews with
barrett noak and petrus kumitsakis
in this paper we're specifically talking
about kind of the computational methods
of simulating fluid flows how do we
accelerate them how do we improve
scaling how do we get more physical
understanding out of our reduced order
models
good
and so
this presentation i'm going to give
today this kind of video
is going to zoom in to these three
little vignettes how can we use ml for
dns how can we use ml for turbulence
modeling and how can we use it for
reduced order modeling in general
and i'm not going to cover nearly the
same depth as we do in this uh this
review paper i'm only going to hit some
highlights uh but you can read more
about it on the archive
okay so for the first one we're going to
talk about direct numerical simulations
and how we can use machine learning to
accelerate these
and before jumping in i want to point
out actually this is a great video by um
by the the lynn flow center and the the
kth stockholm team
what i want to point out is that
these fluid simulations at full fidelity
actually solving the whole navier-stokes
equations for example on this section of
a wing here
is extremely expensive because the
navier stokes has so many scales in
space and in time
it basically takes super computers
months
even to sim to simulate simplified
versions of the flows
that are not as complex as some of the
flows we experience in the real world
and we know that with moore's law we
will have faster better computers if we
just wait
but even with moore's law it's expected
that there are decades if not centuries
of waiting that we'll have to do to
simulate the full fidelity flows
that we really care about around full
aircraft and submarines and things like
that
and for lots of applications and design
and iteration and optimization you know
if i want to design a shape of a wing to
have better properties i'd have to run
the simulation many many times i can't
just run it once i'd have to iterate it
over the shape and run it thousands of
times
so that's the motivation of using these
machine learning models to maybe
accelerate these uh cfd solutions can we
can we get things that are like full dns
but at a fraction of the cost
that's that's one big question the
community is asking i just love this
video it's so cool
uh and so one of the
kind of most impressive recent
demonstrations of this is this paper
by kochkov at all
and i know michael brenner and stephon
hoyer have been working in this vein for
a while so they have some some prior
work in this
where essentially they use a deep neural
network to essentially figure out a
correction term
so if you simulate your flow on a coarse
resolution grid
you can try to upscale that to a fine
resolution grid but there's going to be
things missing the turbulence is going
to be off if you do that naively
and so what they do in this paper is
essentially learn a deep neural network
correction term
that allows you to upscale
the
upscale the
the low resolution image to capture
the relevant features of the high
resolution map
and so you can see that kind of just a
naive uh low resolution so the high
resolution is 4096 by 4096
very high resolution and the low
resolution is 128 by 128.
and you'll notice that if you kind of
naively do this
and you try to upscale as the flow
evolves in time you miss a lot of the
relevant features of the high resolution
just with naive upscaling but when you
use these neural network correctors you
actually get a lot better features
and this is relying on the statistics of
the flow kind of what neighboring
grid cells are doing and what my past
experience of flows is telling me is
likely to be the high resolution
structure uh given what i'm seeing at
low resolution
so there's actually a lot of overlap
between this and what we call a large
eddy simulation where you try to infer
kind of what the the upscaling map would
be from course resolution images
and just some scaling here you can see i
mean i really like this so this shows
kind of the vorticity correlation versus
the time step
and what you see is that uh as you okay
so so the the ground truth is this this
40 96 uh kind of pale yellow curve here
where basically it's it's perfectly uh
the solution at each time step is
perfectly correlated with itself because
it's the truth
and then as i decrease the resolution
using traditional down sampling at some
point in time my solution falls off and
starts to become unaccurate or decorated
with the truth
and what you'll see is that the
neural network correction even at the
lowest resolution 128 by 128 in dashed
blue
is giving you performance almost as good
somewhere between
a 5 512 and a 1024 resolution
so it's giving you the ability to
upscale by somewhere between four and
eight times just using this neural
network
and that's pretty remarkable so it's not
you know as good as the full direct
numerical simulation
but it's giving you a lot of the
information of an even finer resolution
grid
because it's using this this kind of
neural network uh statistical correlator
so i think that's really cool
that you can get this massive upscaling
performance
now there's actually earlier work so i
mentioned that stephan hoyer and michael
brenner and their colleagues johai
barcenae and jason
hickey have done prior work trying to
build machine learning methods that
actually accelerate fluid simulations
and this is a really cool paper when
this came out in pnas this was one of
the major steps forward
in kind of bringing machine learning
into simulation
where essentially what they did was they
learned a computational stencil
for computing so essentially these
discretizations of pdes you often use
finite difference stencils
they learned a stencil using
neural network interpolation
that was more accurate than these high
order polynomial interpolations that
we're used to using in the community
so here you can see if i only had these
orange diamonds this is our kind of our
interpolation points
the kind of industry standard polynomial
interpolation in blue would do a pretty
poor job but their neural network
interpolator in purple almost perfectly
matches the exact solution
and it gives you a much better
prediction a much better correlation of
the predicted versus the exact so you
want this to be a straight line
and this was a really neat uh neat paper
when it came out and there's been a lot
of follow-on and build-up work since
there so one of the ones i really like
is this paper by stevens and colonias in
theoretical and computational fluid
dynamics in 2020 and this is a special
issue on machine learning
for computational fluids
where they essentially investigated that
kind of idea of learning these finite
difference uh stencils
with neural network corrections so this
is an improved fifth order finite
difference scheme
for
capturing shocks in a in a really kind
of
stiff uh shock forming system
and you can see in this i really like
this plot this is kind of a useful plot
where you have error versus runtime
and what you want is you want to be in
this lower left corner here you want
very low run time very low error
and what you see is that there are
trade-offs so the we know 5js is kind of
you know one of these industry standard
shock capturing schemes in blue
and this we know nnn is this neural
network correction proposed in this
paper
and so it's not always better some of
the blue points are are faster but on
average it has lower error and is faster
it's kind of closer to this lower left
corner than the traditional blue
uh scheme
and so that's pretty cool that you can
you can with machine learning learn uh
improvements to these these classical
methods that have been optimized with
you know rigorous mathematics so that's
pretty neat
and there's another set of work by by
stevens and colonias that i think is
really cool
called finite net where essentially they
build a convolutional lstn so an lstm is
a recurrent neural network good for time
series prediction
and they have a convolutional piece so
that you can apply this to kind of high
dimensional
you know multi-dimensional fluids and so
you can kind of use this to find
different scales and how they evolve
using
using the lstm
and this is formulated for general
spatial temporal pdes and i think this
is a very promising architecture
okay good um
so that was one kind of vignette that we
discussed in this review paper another
big area of potential improvement using
machine learning uh and fluids kind of
for computation
is to speed up our computations of
poisson's equation or kind of a forced
laplace equation this comes up all the
time in fluid solvers so what you often
do is you take an advective step to move
things forward in your flow
and then you have to check and see if
incompressibility has been violated and
then you have to kind of correct
the flow field to make sure that it's
incompressible so incompressibility
means the divergence of my velocity
field is zero
and often times the correction term
after you take the advective step looks
like this
so you basically have to solve this is a
kind of a poisson's equation for the
pressure
where the
non-zero
compressibility is the forcing term so
this is you know the laplacian of
pressure
is equal to this uh this forcing term
which which is you know how we get
poisson's equation
now it turns out that this is one of the
more solving this equation to get that
correction is one of the most expensive
steps in many cfd solvers computational
fluid dynamic solvers
and so there are approaches to try to
learn with machine learning how to solve
this more efficiently and to kind of
speed up this step so that's one large
area of computational research not
really an expert in this but i have been
told by ricardo and others that this is
one of the really expensive steps
something i think is really cool
is that you can actually build in this
kind of incompressibility condition
as a constraint in your machine learning
algorithm so if you're trying to build a
neural network that can predict a flow
field evolving
it might make sense you know you have an
error term which is you want your
estimated flow field u hat to be close
to the true flow field u so this would
be a loss term in training
but you might add another loss term to
penalize large
divergences because we know that we
should be having divergence free
solutions
so this is a really cool uh idea
proposed by rui wang and rose yu
and rose's group is doing lots of neat
work kind of baking in physics and
symmetries and knowledge of the fluid
flow equations and dynamics into these
neural network turbulent solvers and her
group is getting really really good
results kind of showing that by baking
in
either symmetries or adding in you know
constraints or regularizers to promote
physicality or physical solutions
you get much better better solutions
so this is one kind of cool example
where the target is the ground truth i
believe this is a rayleigh bernard
convection with cells
and their um
i believe this is called turbulent uh
turbulent flow net i think is what it's
called
gets a lot more of the the subtle
features of the flow than the other
kinds of simple or naive networks you
could design like a resnet or a gan um
to do the same job
so long story short baking in some
physics and some symmetries here and
kind of decomposing the flow in an
intelligent way allows you to get a lot
more of the fine structure
in this in this reconstruction
and actually rose just gave a fantastic
seminar in our physics informed machine
learning seminar series at university of
washington so i'll post a link to her
video so you can you know hear her talk
much more detail about how to actually
do this
and you'll actually know how to do it
once you listen to her
cool
so that uh is kind of
the vignette of how we how we use
machine learning for computational
fluids in the the fullest fidelity sense
for direct numerical simulations
there's other things you can do um
decreasing the size of your domain
is a big part so oftentimes people use
big domains so that the far field
conditions are simple
and so there have been some techniques
that try to use machine learning to
decrease the size of the domain and
again you can read about this in the
paper
so the second vignette is how you use
machine learning for turbulence modeling
les and rands and again i have a whole
video series on this so i'm going to
give this kind of a fast treatment at a
high level
and there's a really great review paper
by durasami yacharino and xiao
where they talk about kind of the
emerging techniques i believe this is
from 2019.
they talk about a lot of the emerging
techniques for rams reynolds average
navier stokes and les largetti
simulations
and so rand's is one of the most popular
turbulence closure
modeling frameworks
you essentially take the navy or stokes
equations you take a time series of
measurements and you average them in
time to get the mean flow field u we
call this big u bar
and you can essentially derive equations
of motion for this big u bar
that are mostly in terms of big u bar
but they have some of these little terms
here which are called reynold stresses
and those depend on the temporal
fluctuations that we've averaged out
and these are generally speaking very
hard to model and so we can use uh
machine learning and other algorithms to
build models for these reynold stresses
and those are important to getting uh
these turbulence closure models
these are really important for things
like measuring uh
quantifying the drag on a wing or on a
truck so if you're designing a wing or a
truck you might be interested in the
reynolds average navy or stokes
equations because you'd want to be able
to compute the drag based on these big
mean
quantities
and so one of the the coolest papers and
this is one of the early ones
to build iran's closure model is this
paper by ling at all
and julia ling essentially what she does
in this paper
is bake in prior knowledge of the
physics this is going to be a theme
if you talk to me i love papers and
approaches where they bake in partial
knowledge of the physics
so that their their networks have this
galilean invariant property that we know
are our rentals uh closures should have
by construction
so what they do is they build a deep
neural network to model those those uh
reynolds stresses essentially and they
have this tensor layer that they can use
to enforce galilean and variance kind of
invariants to different kinds of
rotations and translations
and they get great results they show
this is a pretty canonical hard problem
where if you have you know turbulent
flow over a bump like this it can
separate
and you know you can think of this also
being over a wing
and that separation point strongly
determines what the drag profile is
going to be
and so the true dns has this little
separation bubble here that you can see
and it's very hard to capture this using
other leading methods
uh but the kind of um
the the the dns using um their approach
and this tensor-based approach actually
get that separation bubble
better
than the other leading methods
so that that's a really cool approach
the other major avenue and so we talk
about other papers that uh that try to
solve this rand's problem using machine
learning
the other big approach in turbulence
modeling is large eddy simulation
and this is kind of like that paper i
showed earlier where you're trying to go
from low resolution to high resolution
this kind of super resolution problem
what we need is essentially a model for
how the the the scales the physics below
the resolution we can compute and
measure
interact with each other so that's
called subgrid scale modeling and that's
a big problem as well
and again one of the earliest and really
great papers on this was by malik and
san
rashid and vadula
where they essentially build a deep
neural network
again
to account for this this kind of sub
grid scale to learn the subgrid could
scale physics in their les models
and so they actually get really really
good kind of
results where they can resolve
structures that are
you know
they can resolve the physics below the
the scale that they're simulating and
dramatically speed up their simulations
because of that
and then one of the third approaches
that we talk about in this paper um and
this is a pretty neat and and very new
one um by neb
nevadi liscombe uh
del oro c and and kumitsakis
is the use of reinforcement learning so
can you learn kind of uh
a policy or you know some multi-agent
reinforcement learning policy for what
those subgrid scale interactions are
so it's kind of an interesting approach
to a very classical problem i don't know
of anyone
before that had used
multi-agent reinforcement learning to
try to represent these subgrid scale
modeling
and again i think this is probably
expensive to train based on my
experience of reinforcement learning
it's usually kind of expensive to train
um
but the policies they get the kind of uh
the output that they get actually has
very good agreement with um
with with the known full fidelity
physics so that's pretty cool you can
see as they increase the reynolds number
you actually get this nice uh kind of
faithful
uh upscaling of smaller and smaller
structures
okay good so that was uh the kind of
turbulence modeling the second piece
and for the third piece that we uh
we talked about in this review we're
going to jump into reduced order models
these are very near and dear to my heart
reduced order models essentially try to
balance as best as possible accuracy and
efficiency
so you want the most efficient model
possible that is as accurate as you need
it to be
and typically to do that you take
training data for a specific flow
configuration and you can learn these
reduced order models for that specific
flow configuration
may be parameterized by a few parameters
and so the big opportunity here in
machine learning for reduced order
modeling and fluids there are two key
things that can be improved
one is finding what is a good reduced
coordinate system so here x represents
my high dimensional fluid flow state
this might be millions or billions of
degrees of freedom
and in reduced order modeling we're
trying to find a few coherent structures
a few dominant patterns in the flow
given by the coefficients of z
that describe most of the things i care
about uh for my high level objectives
maybe you know measuring lift or drag or
controlling the flow
and so finding a good coordinate system
z a good low dimensional coordinate
system is one of the first areas we can
really innovate with machine learning
and then figuring out how those coherent
structures co-evolve in time through a
some kind of a dynamical systems model
is another area that we can use machine
learning
so for example we'll talk about how we
can use deep
convolutional autoencoders to build a
good coordinate system
and once you have a good coordinate
system you could use an lstm or some
other recurrent neural network to build
the dynamical systems model in that
latent space and there's a lot of
choices here i can choose different
embeddings fee and i can choose
different ways of building the dynamics
f it's kind of a mix and match grab bag
and so this builds on classical work
most of the classical reduced order
modeling theory for fluids and this goes
back you know 50 years at least
is built on the singular value
decomposition which we call principal
components analysis and statistics and
proper orthogonal decomposition in
fluids
so if you have a high dimensional flow
system like this flow past a cylinder
we know that we can compute the singular
value decomposition if we subtract out
the average flow u bar we can compute
the singular value decomposition
and get a tailor-made orthogonal basis
that best represents this flow field
with as few orthogonal modes as possible
and those coefficients a
are the the amplitudes of these modes
those would be the latent state the the
reduced vector a is the minimal amount
of information i need to represent this
particular flow field maybe i only need
six numbers in a six you know a column
vector a with six elements to represent
these six amplitudes that's a huge
compression from tens of thousands of
grid points down to six amplitudes in a
so that's what we've been doing for a
long time
and you can think of this as a
in in kind of modern machine learning as
a shallow linear auto encoder you could
essentially compute this using uh this
shallow linear auto encoder so these
modes fee would be given by this
this matrix the column of this matrix u
and uh
there is an analog here
i would not recommend ever computing the
svd
using a deep neur using a neural network
this is only supposed to be a cartoon
analogy to show that the thing we've
been doing for 50 years we could
technically get away with doing it with
a neural network
but what's nice is that this linear
neural network gives me a linear
subspace where my data is explained
if i allow this to be a deep neural
network and i allow myself to have
nonlinear activation functions i can
maybe get better compressed coordinates
in z maybe i can learn some nonlinear
sub manifold that gives me even better
compression okay
and so the original picture so the kind
of classic picture here is you you train
uh with with data with your your
specific flow data you try to learn this
coordinate system z for example using
the proper orthogonal decomposition i
showed you
and if you have that orthogonal basis
you can do a galerkin projection of the
navy or stokes equations onto that basis
to get a low order differential equation
for how those amplitudes evolve in time
but if you again if you relax that so
instead of a linear svd you do this deep
auto encoder we can often get much
better coordinates in this latent space
z much better compression using these
deep autoencoders and you can do things
like add a convolutional layer here
so that work i showed you by
stevens and colonias you know they're
looking at convolutional neural networks
to extract features you could have
variational auto encoders there's a lot
of flavors
of auto encoders you can use to extract
good latent spaces z
and so essentially you can get better
compression and instead of getting you
know a subspace a three-dimensional
subspace that describes these dynamics
maybe you learn that there's a
two-dimensional sub-manifold a lower
dimensional sub-manifold using these
deep auto encoders
so a lot a lot of opportunity to learn
better coordinates
using deep auto encoders that's the
first point and the second point is like
i mentioned
we don't have to have the governing
equations and galerkin project we can
also build these f these dynamical
systems models for z dot equals f of z
using kind of machine learning
regressions things like dynamic mode
decomposition or cindy the sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics or
an rnn an lstm or an echo state network
so this is really nice you can kind of
pick modularly i can
use linear coordinates and use some of
these modern machine learning models
or i can use non-linear coordinates and
i can either do classical galerkin
projection or again use some of these
modern modeling techniques
and so there's lots and lots of
different ways you can combine these
things
one of the really powerful recent
methods is by lee and karl berg this is
a 2020 jcp paper
where they basically show that you can
get much better reduced order model
performance using these deep
uh
these deep convolutional auto encoders
to extract kind of multi-scale features
in a non-linear way as opposed to the
the proper orthogonal decomposition i
showed you earlier
uh and they you know they do this for
lots and lots of different test systems
this one i think is a system that has
some uh
you know
some
stiff physics in this in the system
and the high fidelity simulation in
yellow that's our ground truth
all of the classic pod roms are these
jiggly solutions they actually do a
really poor job
away from this transition
whereas using these deep coordinate
systems here actually allow you you can
barely even see it because it perfectly
lays on top
of the high fidelity simulation
so either deep galerkin rom that's
galerkin projection or this lspg rom
that's their kind of custom
uh galerkin ron this this least squares
petrov galerkin
rom
do much better when you use this deep
convolutional uh coordinate system
so using classical galerkin models is
still improved dramatically by using
these deep convolutional autoencoders
another
kind of the flip side of that is okay
what if i don't want to use the
governing equations to go lurk and
project the dynamics what if that's
really expensive and i don't want to
take a working code to do this galerkin
projection
jared callahan and john kristoff lazzo
showed that similarly for these complex
fluid examples you can use this
autoencoder structure to learn a very
very low dimensional latent space for
example in the shear driven cavity
and you can use regression like sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics
this cindy approach
to learn regression models for the
dynamics in the latent space
so you don't need any access to the
governing equations you don't need to
know that there's a navy or stokes
equation you don't need a working
simulation
to do any of this you just need data
to build an auto encoder to find that
latent space and then you can build
these regression models in that latent
space
this is another really really cool vein
of work
by by baron nowak mark
luke pasteur
and they're a fantastic phd student nan
deng
i was fortunate enough to be on on his
committee and learn about all of his
great work
where essentially they have done a
similar approach
where they are learning these cindy
models these sparse non-linear models
for this very complex flow past the
fluidic pinball this three cylinder
configuration
and this example is so cool as you
increase the reynolds number the
reynolds number of the system
it goes through a number of pretty
sophisticated bifurcations um so it goes
through the hops bifurcation a pitchfork
knee mark sacker all the way to chaos
and they're able to capture this rich
rich phenomenology as you increase the
flow velocity you get all of these
different phenomena they're able to
capture it by using these modern sparse
model identification techniques to build
these reduced order models
so very powerful stuff
now going back to the um
oh yeah this one is a bit of a different
flavor and this is just working i have
to show you because it's one of my
favorite papers out there this is from
2014 so kind of the early days of
machine learning this is not deep
learning this is work by erica kaiser
bear noack and friends
and the idea is
that you can use relatively simple
techniques in clustering to build that
low dimensional latent space that low
dimensional variable that i was talking
about
so here in the lorentz system if you do
something like a k-means clustering you
can break this up into 10 different
clusters
and the center of those clusters whether
or not you're in one of these different
rainbow
regions
is the state of your system
and so you can basically take a long
time trajectory and you can figure out
how often you transition from state 1 to
state 2 or state 2 to state 3 and so on
and so forth
and you can build a probability model a
transition state model for how the
system probabilistically transitions
from these clusters
and i think this is just a brilliant way
of reduced order modeling very complex
chaotic systems and reducing it to
relatively simple linear transition
dynamics
and erica
showed that you can do this on much more
complex systems very high dimensional
nonlinear fluid systems like this mixing
layer that has you know maybe a hundred
thousand or a million degrees of freedom
you can still cluster your phase space
you can still do data driven clustering
to find you know 10 or 20 clusters
and count the probability of
transitioning between those clusters
and when you do graph analysis on this
you learn really interesting things
about your physics for example that
there is a kelvin-helmholtz
mechanism that's the transition from two
to three to four
and there's vortex pairing that's
another set of transitions and there's
this what they call the flipper mode
between these two different
phenomenologies
so you know really powerful things you
can do with relatively simple machine
learning i mean this is you know k means
clustering one of the textbook examples
you can build these beautiful reduced
order models for complex systems
okay the last thing i'll show you and
this is actually halfway between
turbulence modeling and reduced order
modeling
this is some fantastic work by sarah
beatham and jessie capisilatro
where they again use that cindy that
sparse nonlinear model identification
technique but instead of building roms
they use it to build
they use it to build turbulence closure
models
so they essentially are modeling the
terms in the turbulence closure and the
rand's equations using these sparse
polynomial or tensorial expressions
and so what they get out and they don't
just use cindy they also look at gene
expression programming as an alternative
method to get these interpretable
expressions
what they get out are turbulence closure
models that can be read by a human their
their analytic expressions equations you
can write down and you can analyze and
study and do analysis on
which is really really cool
um and i've i just realized
learned recently um that there is also
work doing this in in climate science so
maybe i'll talk about that at some point
okay
so that was a a whirlwind tour through
this review paper and believe it or not
that was only a small fraction of the
the things we we talked about so ricardo
vinuesa and myself in this archive paper
on how you can use machine learning
to accelerate direct numerical
simulations to improve high fidelity
simulations
to improve kind of medium fidelity
turbulence closure modeling
and how to uh improve
kind of the scaling and the
interpretability and just the general
operation of these you know
very very tailored reduced order models
so again from highest fidelity to lowest
fidelity there are many many
opportunities to embed machine learning
into the process and to get better
computational fluid models
so a few takeaways that i think are
really important and we talk about these
a little bit too
we as a community
have to be committed to reproducible
research to open source codes to open
source data and to good benchmark
problems we need to have agreed upon
benchmark problems in these areas so
that when we develop new machine
learning techniques we can compare them
in a head-to-head kind of
apples-to-apples way on these different
canonical problems
and that means we have to be open and
have best practices for reproducible and
open research
another thing that i think is incredibly
important is when you are saying if you
if you want to claim that you are using
machine learning to improve direct
numerical simulations maybe you get
faster models
you have to include the
time it took to generate your training
data
okay because that oftentimes is
neglected when we talk about the
numerical scaling of these machine
learning solutions
and it's often
very very expensive to build the
training data that you need to train
your your models
now in some cases like in reduced order
models i don't mind if i have a very
expensive offline training phase as long
as my model is very fast online when i
use it you know for my flying quadrotor
or whatever i'm using it for
but if you're claiming to use machine
learning to actually improve simulations
direct numerical simulations
you know sometimes it might still be
faster to just compute the direct
numerical simulation if you need enough
training data and it takes so much time
to generate those models
unless your models are general enough
that you can use them lots of times in
the future okay so that's another really
important point is you have to be very
careful when you're doing these
comparisons
and maybe the last point i'll make is
these methods have been optimized by
really smart people for you know decades
and decades and decades right people
have been developing
just incredible algorithms for
all three of these uh these pieces of
computational fluid dynamics for you
know 50 years or more
and so it's very hard for machine
learning to come in and out of the gate
and beat these approaches
and so i think we have to be willing to
have kind of a learning curve in how we
use these machine learning algorithms in
these fields you can't expect these to
immediately built beat the state of the
art
so if you get promising results we have
to be critical on the one hand um you
know because these there are such good
existing methods
but we also have to think you know how
are these machine learning methods going
to look five years from now 10 years
from now if they keep getting the same
development that these classical
approaches have had
okay so if you're interested in this
topic i really encourage you to check
out this paper there's a ton more
examples there
and this is such a fast growing field
you know in a year we're going to need
to have a whole new set of examples so
really great area to be doing research
in
and i hope you all enjoy this and you
know have some ideas of your own to to
get started with all right thank you